[Music]
on your knees
[Music]
hi uncle jack the old cabin looks good
country will be good for you this lake
has a way of healing things thanks for
driving
okay bye bye
i'm over this jimmy read the room you
know the protocol
that's not how we talk that's not what
we do
hey hi
billy we have an unintended clean up
your goddamn mess
don't you make me have to come out there
please i'm begging you please please
please you don't have to do this i
promise are you waiting for billy
don't move on your knees now
i'm a cop what happened she assaulted me
they're lying
she murdered someone this guy's a cop
he's not gonna shoot another cop
billy get my gun run
[Music]
we got a problem put her out of her
misery and then let's finish this
i can hear you in there where's your
friend
shannon you can trust me what we need is
evidence i need my camera
everything that you need to know is on
there
there's no quitting now you understand
okay
bring me the girl jack and your niece
stay safe
i swear if you touch my knees
[Music]
we're in this together it gets real
tricky when families involved doesn't it
jack
i know men like you you use people to
get what you want
but i'm that chick you shouldn't have
messed with
[Music]
[Music]
you